[Music]
welcome back so we've been talking about
the SVD and we have this nice
interpretation of the singular value
decomposition of a matrix X in terms of
the product of a unitary matrix u
diagonal matrix Sigma and a unitary
matrix V transpose and remember that
these unitary matrices can only rotate
space they can only rotate vectors but
they don't change the angles between
vectors or the lengths of vectors okay
and Sigma's diagonal so it can only
scale directions XY and Z okay and we
talked about how if you draw a unit
sphere in one space and you take all of
the little vectors V in this unit sphere
and you multiply them by the X matrix
then you get this deformed ellipsoid in
this output space and how the SVD can
essentially tell you the shape of this
ellipsoid based on the SVD of the matrix
X in particular the columns of U so you
will essentially tell you how this that
the orientation of this ellipsoid how
its rotated Sigma will tell you how the
sphere gets stretched okay so so the the
dimensions of Sigma the the terms the
singular values and Sigma tell you how
much this sphere gets stretched into an
ellipsoid which directions get stretched
out which directions get smushed and
then you take that smushed ellipsoid and
you rotate it through the U matrix okay
that's the interpretation of the SVD of
this matrix multiplication so that's
what I'm going to walk you through in
this jupiter' notebook here we basically
are going to create a sphere so we're
going to create a matrix of rotations
we're going to rotate in the X direction
the Y direction and in the Z direction
according to these theta angles PI over
15 minus PI ninths and minus PI
twentieths
and then we're also going to stretch out
in the first direction by a factor of
three we're going to keep the second
direction exactly the same we're going
to multiply that Sigma by one
and then the third direction we're going
to smush by a factor of two that Sigma
three is point five okay so this
ellipsoid is going to get stretched out
and smooshed and then it's gonna get
rotated in the in the X direction the Y
direction and the Z direction based on
these angles okay that's so so what
we're doing is we're building an X
matrix where we know exactly how its
deforming this sphere and then we're
going to compute the SVD of X and verify
that you and Sigma do what we think it
should do okay so that's what we're
gonna do here and essentially we're
gonna create these three rotation
matrices a rotation about the x axis or
rotation about the y axis and rotation
about the z axis at these theta angles
you can go look up a rotation matrices
if you don't remember how to construct
these and we're building our X matrix so
that it it first takes us ellipsoid and
stretches out by Sigma and smushes it so
scales by Sigma then rotation about X
rotation about Y rotation about z ok and
then what we're going to do is we're
essentially going to plot the 3-sphere
and we're going to multiply that three
sphere by X and plot the deformed
ellipsoid so that's what we're going to
plot here and you can download this code
from databook u-dub comm and actually
walk through what all of the features
are doing and you see this very nice
representation of our original sphere
and how it gets mapped through
multiplication by X into this elongated
sphere that's three times longer in one
direction the same length and in another
direction and smashed by a factor of two
in the third direction and also at this
this inclined angle given by by those
three rotation angles okay now what's
interesting is that if I go back up here
so so this is the case where we know the
answer we built X specifically to
stretch and rotate to be a deformation
and then a unitary transformation but if
instead of building X that way I compute
the SVD of my X matrix then what I claim
is that the S the Sigma matrix from the
SVD will capture the the stretching
factors and the U matrix from the SV
we'll capture those rotation matrices
the RZ x ry x r x matrix and so if
instead i just map my sphere through
this transformation x equals u times x
sigma then if I use that matrix I will
also recover this exact same rotation
and stretching matrix so let's do that
good and now we're gonna plot the sphere
map through just u times Sigma and again
we see this ellipsoid that is in the
right orientation it stretched out and
so on and so forth now if you're paying
attention you'll probably notice that
the original ellipsoid was blue on the
top and yellow on the bottom and this
one is flipped and that's because the
SVD is unique up to sign changes of the
columns of U and V so what I suspect
happened here is one or more of these of
the vectors in this rotation matrix got
multiplied by negative one and the
corresponding column of ve also got not
multiplied by negative one and what that
ended up doing is basically just
flipping the color scheme but it's still
the same ellipsoid it's still the same
stretching and rotation and if you had
that data matrix X you could mine what
that Sigma and you were and it matches
our intuition about stretching and a
rotation okay
so that's kind of neat you can also
verify if you want that the V matrix
that pops out is an identity matrix
right because it's a we know that X is
built by a left unitary matrix times the
diagonal matrix and the right matrix
would then be the identity okay and if
you actually verify that what you'll
find is that it's if the identity except
maybe some of the columns are multiplied
by a negative 1 and then the
corresponding column of U would be
multiplied by negative 1 ok great so
there's this nice clean geometric
interpretation of the singular value
decomposition of a matrix X as
decomposing that X into how it stretches
and rotates kind of a unit sphere of
vectors okay thank you